EXPERT WHO HAS NO DETAILS ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 43, AMERICA STILL IN
SHUTDOWN.
NOW, I ACTUALLY THINK I COULD DO
THREE HOURS OF TV TONIGHT, THIS
IS WHEN I REALLY MISS MY RADIO
SHOW, AND I STILL WOULDN’T GET
THROUGH ALL OF THE MATERIAL I
HAVE TO GET THROUGH.
WE ARE ASKING QUESTIONS, WE’RE
DOING THE DIGGING THAT OLD-TIME
REAL JOURNALISTS USED TO DO, YOU
KNOW, IN THE OLDEN DAYS BEFORE
OBAMA WORSHIP AND TRUMP
DEMONIZATION BECAME THE 24/7
FOCUS.
WELL, MOST GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
OUTSIDE OF THE BLUE STATES HAVE
COME TO THE REALIZATION THAT
IT’S TIME TO GET ON WITH IT.
IT’S TIME TO MOVE BEYOND A 24/7
FOCUS ON COVID-19.
IT’S TIME TO MOVE INTO RECOVERY
AND RENEWAL.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, THE RED STATES
ARE LEADING THE WAY.
>> WE HAD IT TAILORED AND
MEASURED APPROACH THAT NOT ONLY
HELPED OUR NUMBERS BE WAY BELOW
WHAT ANYONE PREDICTED, BUT ALSO
DID LESS DAMAGE TO OUR STATE
GOING FORWARD.
A LOT OF THIS IS CONFIDENCE AND
BUILDING CONFIDENCE WITH THE
PUBLIC.
>> I BELIEVE WE CAN REENGAGE OUR
ECONOMY WHILE STILL CONTAINING
THE CORONAVIRUS USING THESE
PROVEN STRATEGIES.
>> Laura: AT SOME POINT, WE
HAVE TO STOP FEEDING THE MEDIA
ON THIS TOPIC.
WHAT I’M SAYING HERE IS KIND OF
A STATEMENT AGAINST INTEREST
BECAUSE AFTER ALL, OUR RATINGS
ARE A FOX IN PRIME TIME HAVE
JUST SOARED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
PANDEMIC.
YOU WANT TO FOR DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU GET IT FROM
US.
BUT TONIGHT, SPEAKING TO YOU AS
A MOM, AS A FRIEND, AS AN
AMERICAN, AND I SAY, IT’S TIME
THAT WE TAKE BACK CONTROL OF OUR
OWN LIVES.
WE DO IT SMARTLY AND WE DO IT
SAFELY.
THE CORONAVIRUS IS LAVISHLY A
TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
I DON’T NEED TO SAY THAT, YOU
ALL KNOW THAT.
IT’S ALSO PARTICULARLY TERRIBLE
THAT CHINA AND THE W.H.O. DID SO
MANY THINGS TO HELP THIS
PANDEMIC SPREAD TO OUR SHORES
AND IT’S UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
FDA DIDN’T GET THE TESTING
WORKING SOONER.
IT’S AWFUL OR THAT
MAYOR de BLASIO -- TOOK ACTION
TO HELP THIS PANDEMIC SPREAD
THROUGHOUT NEW YORK CITY.
AND HOW MUCH COVID SPREADING WAS
DONE IN LATE FEBRUARY BY THE
CROWD THAT WAS GATHERING AROUND
SAN FRAN GRAN NAN IN CHINATOWN?
SPEAK OF THE CAUTIONS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN BY OUR CITY.
WE KNOW THAT THERE’S CONCERN
ABOUT TOURISM, TRAVEL.
ALL THROUGHOUT THE WORLD OF WHAT
WE THINK IS VERY SAFE TO BE IN
CHINATOWN AND HOPE THAT OTHERS
WILL COME.
>> Laura: WELL, THEY KEPT
COMING, NANCY, BUT AT THIS
POINT, BEYOND PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE, THE FUNDING, THE
SCIENTIFIC WORK FOR THERAPIES
AND MEDICAL TREATMENTS, THERE’S
REALLY NOT ALL THAT MUCH MORE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT CAN DO
BECAUSE YOU SLEPT TOO MANY NEW
COVID REGULATIONS ON BUSINESSES
AND THAT MAY END UP DRIVING THEM
TO INSOLVENCY.
WHEN HE BUSINESSES, RESTAURANTS,
ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES, TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET.
I THINK NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
HAVE TO HAVE FAITH IN AMERICAN
INNOVATION AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
ON EVERYTHING WE’VE WORKED FOR.
OTHERWISE ALL OF THESE EFFORTS
OF THE PAST SEVEN WEEKS, ALL OF
OUR EFFORTS OF THE PAST COUPLE
OF CENTURIES ARE GOING TO END UP
BEING FOR KNOTS.
WE’VE NEVER ALLOWED A FOREIGN
ENEMY TO ROB US OF OUR FREEDOM
AND WE CAN’T LET A DEADLY VIRUS
DO IT EITHER.
WE DIDN’T SHUTDOWN AMERICA IN
1968 DURING THE HONG KONG FLU.
THAT WAS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC OF
THE H3 AND TO VIRUS.
IT KILLED 100,000 AMERICANS,
MOSTLY THOSE 65 AND OLDER.
FAST FORWARD TO OUR HORRIFIC FLU
SEASON THIS YEAR, WHICH WE
TOUCHED ON BRIEFLY LAST NIGHT.
NEW YORK’S CURRENT INFLUENZA
SEASON HAS BEEN ONE OF THE WORST
ON RECORD.
IN THE FIRST WEEK OF JANUARY,
10,076 LAB CONFIRMED CASES.
FOR COMPARISON, THERE WERE 3,736
SUCH CASES DURING THE SAME TIME
IN A 2018F IN 2019 SEASON IN
NEW YORK.
NOW FAST FORWARD TO THE WEEK
ENDING ON MARCH 14TH, LOOK AT
THAT MAP.
YOU SEE IT THERE, IT’S DARK
BLUE.
THERE YOU GO.
IT’S DARK BLUE, THAT’S THE COLOR
CODING FOR BASICALLY A FLU OUT
OF CONTROL.
AND THE WEEK ENDING ON
MARCH 20TH, WELL, IT’S STILL BAD
BUT GETTING BETTER, THERE IT IS.
BUT THEN IN THE WEEK ENDING ON
APRIL 4TH, WOW, THE FLU VIRUS IS
BASICALLY GONE.
IS THAT BECAUSE OF A FEW WEEKS
OF SOCIAL DISTANCING?
FAST-FORWARD IT.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THE
DROP-OFF WOULD HAVE BEEN THAT
SIGNIFICANT GIVEN THE FLU SPREAD
WITHIN FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY IN
CRAMPED NEW YORK METRO AREA
APARTMENTS WHERE COVID ALSO
SPREAD REALLY FAST.
AND THEN THERE WAS A REALLY
WEIRD DROP-OFF.
WE’VE BEEN TRYING TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
MAYBE SOME OF YOU CAN HELP US.
WEEK 12 IN THIS FLU COUNTING
WEEK.
IT’S KIND OF WEIRD, THEY START
AT THE END OF AUGUST AND THEY GO
THROUGH THE FOLLOWING AUGUST,
BUT WEEK 12, ABOUT THE END OF
MARCH.
THERE WERE 3,336 CASES,
ALL RIGHT?
INFLUENZA CASES IN NEW YORK, BUT
WEEK 13, THE NUMBER DROPPED TO
764 CASES.
THAT’S DOWN MORE THAN 77%.
WEEK 14 DROPPED TO 193 CASES.
WEEK 15 DROPPED TO 143 CASES,
THE ENTIRE STATE OF NEW YORK.
WE REACHED OUT TO NEW YORK STATE
HEALTH OFFICIALS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND THESE RADICAL DROPS
IN FLU CASES.
WHILE, THEY TRIED TO TELL US
THAT DROPS LIKE THIS ARE NORMAL
SAYING IN 2018 WEEKS 8-10, WE
SAW A DROP IN CASES FROM 13,000
TO 3689, OVER 10,000 IN TWO
WEEKS, DIFFICULT TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES OR
DECREASES FROM WEEK TO WEEK, BUT
THAT’S NOT EVEN CLOSE
PERCENTAGEWISE TO THE TWO GO
CONSECUTIVE WEEKS OF OVER 70%
DECREASES IN FLU CASES THIS
YEAR.
ONE REASON BEHIND THOSE HUGE
DROPS COULD BE THAT AT THE END
OF WEEK 12 IN LATE MARCH,
GOVERNOR CUOMO DID PUT THAT
STATE ON LOCKDOWN.
THAT MAY HAVE CONVINCED PEOPLE
TO STAY HOME, BUT WE DON’T KNOW
THAT AND NEITHER DO STATE HEALTH
OFFICIALS.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE WERE STILL AT
STILL OUT OF GROCERY STORES,
PHARMACIES, AND WE STILL HAVE A
LOT OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS OUT
THERE.
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS WILL PROBABLY BE
DEBATING THIS FOR YEARS.
THERE’S A NATURAL LAG IN SOME
DATA REPORTING, SO WE ARE GOING
TO CHECK BACK IN A FEW WEEKS.
WE CERTAINLY DO NOT WISH TO
THINK THAT INFLUENZA DEATH IN
THIS HORRIBLE FLU SEASON IN
NEW YORK ARE BEING LOGGED
INCORRECTLY AS COVID DEATHS,
THAT WOULD ERODE THE PUBLIC’S
TRUST IN THE EXPERTS.
WE CAN ASK QUESTIONS, WE CAN SAY
ARE PEOPLE DYING AT HOME WITH
COVID OR ARE THEY DYING AT HOME
WITH A REGULAR FLU BUT THEY’RE
FEARFUL OF GOING TO HOSPITAL?
ARE THOSE CASES BEING LOGGED AT
ALL?
WE MAY NEVER KNOW.
BUT REMEMBER, EVEN ONE EARLY ON
WE WERE WARNED THAT THIS FLU
SEASON WAS GOING TO BE
PARTICULARLY DEADLY COME OUT WE
DIDN’T PULL KIDS FROM SCHOOL.
REMEMBER, WE PLAYED THOSE CLIPS
FOR YOU LAST NIGHT.
PEOPLE WERE WARNING ABOUT THIS,
THIS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
WORST ON RECORD.
BUT STILL WE DIDN’T REQUIRE
PEOPLE TO WEAR MASKS ON PLANES
OR IN GROCERY STORES AND WE
DIDN’T DECIDE TO RUIN OUR
ECONOMY.
BUT THEN COVID HIT AND IT WAS
LIKE THIS FLU SEASON THAT WE
WERE HEARING ABOUT IS GOING TO
BE SO HORRIFIC NEVER HAPPENED AT
ALL.
THE MEDIA NEVER TALKED ABOUT IT
AND EVEN OUR INFECTIONS DISEASE
EXPERTS DIDN’T REALLY ADDRESS IT
AS TIME WENT ON.
WHY?
I THINK WE NEED ANSWERS SO WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED HERE AND HOW DEADLY
COVID REALLY WAS.
WE WILL FACE MORE VIRUSES IN THE
FUTURE, WE KNOW THAT, OF COURSE
WE WILL AND WE CANNOT ALLOW THEM
TO BRING US TO A STANDSTILL
MIGHT JUST HAPPEN.
WE CAN’T DO IT AGAIN.
DON’T FORGET, WE HAVE INFLUENZA
VACCINES.
A LOT OF YOU PROBABLY GET THEM
AND WE STILL HAVE A HORRENDOUS
MORTALITY NUMBER THIS YEAR AND
IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
THE FLU VACCINE IS BY ANY
ESTIMATE FROM 45% TO 55%
EFFECTIVE IN A YEAR.
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT TYPES OF
THE VIRUS.
NO ONE CAN SAY THAT ANY
DEMOCRAT -- LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING WE TALKED ABOUT OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS, YOU
CANNOT SAY HONESTLY THAT ANY
DEMOCRAT ON THE SCENE NOW WOULD
HAVE HANDLED THIS CRISIS
MARKEDLY BETTER.
LOOK AT WHAT CUOMO IS BEING
ACCUSED OF NOW WITH THE STUFF
GOING ON WITH THE SENIOR HOME.
THE PRESIDENT SOLVED THE VENTS
PROBLEM FOR THE BLUE STATES LIKE
NEW YORK.
HOSPITAL ERS WERE NOT
OVERWHELMED, THAT WAS THE GOAL
OF FLATTENING THE CURVE.
THAT WAS HIS MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED, BUT IN A RAILWAY,
HE REALLY ACCOMPLISHED THAT
MISSION.
HE AND HIS TEAM HAVE DEVOTED DAY
AND NIGHT TO HELPING AMERICA
AMERICA THROUGH THIS TERRIBLE
TIME.
THEY DESERVE GRATITUDE.
INSTEAD THEY GET ENDLESS GRIEF.
MEANWHILE, HOUSE DEMOCRATS, WE
TALKED ABOUT IT, ANNOUNCED TODAY
THAT NOT EVEN GOING TO COME BACK
TO TOWN ANYTIME SOON, SO THEY’RE
PROTECTING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
OWN COMFORT AS AMERICANS
CONTINUE TO SUFFER.
HOW CAN ANYONE TAKE CONGRESS
SERIOUSLY WHEN THEY’RE NOT EVEN
HERE?
THE PEOPLE ARE WATCHING THEM AND
I HOPE LEARNING, LEARNING WHO
WAS ON THEIR SIDE, WHO’S
FIGHTING FOR THEM, WHO WANTS
THEM TO GET BACK TO THE PRECOVID
LIVES AS SOON AS AND SAFELY AS
POSSIBLE.